hier jacques bonsoir ça va
donc les filles le 1 et les garçons fois
que c'est assez facile ce soir d'animer
cette émission parce que d'un côté
bien alors bien beau jake lors de votre
dernière visite ici c'était en 2001 tout
allait pour le mieux un chat qui innerve
extraordinaire je sais que serge july a
fumé trois tâches de cette herbe ils
étaient rétamer la une de libé était
très drôle d'ailleurs la semaine qui a
suivi et puis ensuite alors voilà la
galère voilà ses membres des partis
d'ici je sais pas ce qui s'est passé la
galère vous nous avez fait quatre pneus
moto racks
sequalum au thorax
ça
c'est un pont qui claque qu'on sait les
armes ça
peut-être un peu peut-être un peu un
vote sanction du non
était un froid sas a foutu une ambiance
en l'air non mais c'est vrai façon quasi
continue alors effectivement série noire
je dirai pas ce que la même année votre
femme a un grave accident de voiture se
retrouve dans le coma à l'hosto et après
ça vous avez plus du tout envie de faire
pierpoljak vous vous dites j'en ai ras
le bol j'en ai ras-le-bol de chanter de
faire le chanteur je suis gavé du biz et
des baby donne risque est une expression
extrêmement rasta gaver du biz et des
babylon riz et vous partez sur un bateau
pierpoljak avec votre fils aîné
et votre femme vous l'avez laissée dans
la nièvre
non ma femme allait martiniquaise donc
elle est en martinique a été retournée
en martinique je vais abandonner la
nièvre pas vraiment non si vous avez des
plantations là bas
c'est dommage devant devenir débauchant
dans vous partez sur un bateau ouais et
là vous voyez c est ce qui vous changent
les idées c'est d'abord le bateau mais
aussi la tempête force 9 que vous
essuyez quoi lasser c'était au stade
large de l'espagne en fait entre la le
la frontière entre l'espagne et le
portugal ouais un endroit qui s'appelle
la guardia grosses branlées de la mort
et a dit grosse branlée de la mort way
serait forcément ouais mais moi je suis
pas un
suis pas un super grand marin tu vois je
vais pas passer ma vie non plus sur les
océans pour moi c'était là c'est la
première grosse
hiatus avec ton fils non on était trois
en fait pierpoljak s'en sort un bateau
voilà donc bizarre quoi la galère le
bateau la grosse blinde la mort et tout
est à ce moment là heureusement tu as
toujours des moments comme ça lors d'une
escale à la grenade vous écouter une
radio locale à vous écouter une radio
locale
du ragga et savoureux donne envie de
chanter
mais chanter et faire père paul jaxx de
trucs différents 1 puisque je chante
déjà depuis je suis toujours donc
voila quoi tu te demandes ce envie
d'être clair que j'aimerais bien parler
là dessus mais vrai je me lance en fait
l'annoncé ce soir bah ouais je vais
essayer à temps l'asie continue voilà et
du retour à paris tu vas chez ta maison
de disques la barclays il t'aime bien
mais ils disent non vas pas de filets de
thunes quand même ils ont été assez dur
d'accord wales est un peu un peu clébard
chez barclay comme
tu le disais je veux pas commencer en
arrivant là tu fais mais je n'en ai pas
taper sur barclays mais c'est vrai que
bon ils ont pas laissés par des mafieux
russes à la bassée jours
autant pour moi et donc tu décides de
produire toi même ton album à la
jamaïque
et a pu les dreadlocks et tout ça non
plus l'un banon tu dis je veux plus
faire croire aux gens que je suis rasta
alors je suis pas rasta exact tiens
c'est afin choc cette histoire de
pneumothorax
mais c'est pas le pneu moto racks
vraiment qu'il ya aussi ils prennent les
acariens dans les dreadlocks
c'est pas bon at war on le dit je sais
moi non mais c'est vrai justement moi
même si j'étais un peu désespéré tous
les jours je les ai coupés et où j'ai
quand même regarder dedans parce que
c'est là je serai aux poudres non les
miens ils étaient bien qu'il était clean
est ce que tu t'es dit finalement un
rasta blanc c'est pas possible donc
comme je suis blanc je vais arrêter de
jouer rasta c'est ça l'histoire ouais
elle blanc sait déjà c'est déjà un non
sens pour être as a way mes yeux à moi
moi je suis pas et est aussi être as tu
as et c'est croire que a élé sélassié
est dieu ouais donc déjà si tu as passé
de si tu cites a passé de trucs là et
que c'est juste une histoire de tenues
de bandits et d'apparence et 2 1 et
d'herbes et de musique et de tout ça bon
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui je
veux dire comme le tu vois que j'ai pas
98% sûrement dû way du truc mais quand
est venu ici la dernière fois tu nous as
10,4 à stains c'était croire à la
divinité de lanveur d'ethiopie avec jean
claude dassier heureusement que tu m'a
pas demandé mais toi est-ce que tu y
crois toi ouais oui c'est vrai dis-moi
mauvaise nouvelle à sa part rejeté à
faire ça y est même si jean gabin qui
était la semaine dernière ouais c'est ce
qu'il a dit dans sa chanson je t'emmerde
je t'encule j'te cuges de merde tu
connais je connais ouais il dit en
parlant de toi je sais pas chanter mais
je sais bien ratonner servir dans la
chanson c'est vrai mais qu'est ce qu'il
a dit en direct et skins avant d'être as
tu as quoi ouais c'est vrai et c'est une
surprise non pas pour moi encore
moi jean gabin je le connais pas mais en
fait après la chanson tous à machin moi
un jour j'ai fait une chanson
soixantaine et poissons panés et à vue
qui est question là web exactement voilà
donc il ya des gens qui connaissent pas
je n'ai pas envie de faire un disque
avec ça c'était surtout pour que lui
l'entendent et et c'est pas pour parce
que j'ai peur qu'ils me tuent ou kim
éclater tout parce que ça c'est un
gaillard tu sais pas ça c'est qu'après
je me suis penché un peu sur gg je suis
tombé sur des interviews de lui et tout
ça et je me suis un peu intéressé à son
cas en fait et en fait j'ai vu que c'est
un
déjà la chanson au départ quand je l'aï
entendu je les trouvais pas mal et après
quand j'ai vu son camp j'ai étudié son
cas on va dire j'ai vu que bon c'est un
gars bien qu'en fera bien il est pas mal
quoi c'est un gars qui vaut le coup en
tout est calé elle a quand même plus
vrai que bon nombre donc il faut il faut
le soutenir ouais mais nous on a soutenu
ici deux semaines derrière lui beaucoup
de même d'ailleurs pour nous parler de
lui non mais l'impression que j'ai là
comme ça si tu reviens c'est la première
fois que tu fais une grosse télé de ces
ça c'est exactement études dit est ce
que ça me gave pas de faire ça
maintenant tu reviens tu dis est ce que
finalement j'ai envie comme ça tous les
deux ans tous les ans de passer chez
ardisson chez fogiel schéma de chaâbane
façon si ici
si si je repars pour tu vois faire du
bateau s en fait ça sera pour ne plus
revenir parce que déjà j'ai créé une
fois en fait j'ai peut-être fait la
connerie pas continuer ce que j'ai
entrepris quoi moi sur la scène je suis
plus à l'aise qui si par exemple tu vois
où
un petit que cette fléchier finalement
non mais je vais me rodez regarde est là
c'est la première mais je vais en faire
don à tout ça va déjà mieux qu'au début
doit il faut qu'ils reviennent qu'il se
remette dans l'île à se chauffer tu sais
c'est d'être une petite dépression et
j'ai l'impression qu'il va pas bien tu
vois il s'auto flagelle
alors qui sait bien c'est toujours ça
moi tu me connais pas rassuré c'est un
as de la bonne ouais elle est trop forte
j'ai l'impression
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus